c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche à ce qui m'énerve un peu en
ce moment c'est que je suis un peu en
galère parce que je viens de chiens de
déménager à lamarck caulaincourt et
l'ascenseur de lamarck caulaincourt ici
avec beaucoup d'étrangers remonter tout
dépend de ton niveau maximum donc je
vois performer doit-on niveau
d'escroquerie avant de dire si on peut
faire un pur sang parce qu'avec grand
escroc sympathique pour faire élections
et tu dois être à 10,3 alors je ne sais
pas si nos tessiture de voix se marient
bien j'ai l'impression que si jusqu'à
aujourd'hui n'a jamais encore fait vous
il ya bien une raison
l'album alors il ya un album qui est
super cool que j'ai découvert pendant le
temps ça s'appelle la vraie vie c'est
l'album de big flo et oli
ils sont déjà là double platine c'est
vrai ils sont comme le platine et du
coup franchement je vous le conseille à
frontalement en cours mais qu'il dit
docteur je crois que j'ai besoin de
lunettes et maggie dit je vous confirme
pas ce que c'est une banque ici j'ai
mais qui lie à sa femme je te ferais
bien l'amour ce soir ça m'a dit votre
chéri ça tombe mal parce que j'ai des
pertes blanches et son mari dit c'est
pas grave moi j'ai du diabète refaire
des meringues
moi je suis une fan de géniale idée qui
va beaucoup me manquer que je l'adorais
ce monsieur l'a d'abord et cinq ans qu'a
tenue puis l'a jamais dit du mal de
personnes par exemple j'ai adoré ça soit
son préféré c'est vivre pour le meilleur
de se vouloir ou tout ça donnait
mary fin ne rien garder que l'amour
qu'est l'amour au pont l'a souvent dit
on m'a souvent confondu avec maurice
lony qu ils rentrent acteurs aussi ma
victoire aujourd'hui c'est clair
bon les sablés aux propos vous je ne
sais pas si je disais j'arrête
le jour où j'aurai terme en tant qu'ami
mots c'est pas tout de suite ça serait
un aveu qui me plaît pas du tout de vous
et que dire que à 40 ans les femmes ne
sont plus désirable et j'aime pas du
tout appuyé cette idée donc je me suis
pas du tout de limites je pense que
c'est vraiment une question de ressenti
et dans vie et si j'ai plus envie
les gens n'ont plus envie de l'acheter
et ça c'est toujours à me battait comme
ça pour moi c'est à dire que c'est une
question de valeurs et très bons jeunes
plants
[Musique]